hi everybody welcome to another episode
of q a about history of Science and
Technology
I see that there are all kinds of
interesting questions
saved up here
let's see
okay IG 11 asks when researching do you
find it's more helpful to stay close to
modern times in terms of content or do
findings from hundreds of years ago also
prove valuable
you know it's an interesting question in
different fields there are different
amounts of look back
you know I have to say like a field like
philosophy
the things that one would debate today
often are the same things that you know
would have been debated by Plato two
thousand years ago it's a field where
many of the core questions one still
turning over the same kinds of questions
today
in a field like mathematics
a theorem proved by Gauss is still in in
the early 1800s for example would still
be a theorem once to use today
although the questions one might ask
might be built on things that were from
the last 10 years or 20 years let's say
different fields work differently
you know in medicine for example if you
write a paper and you've got references
from to papers 100 years ago people will
kind of look kind of like oh no that
can't possibly you know how can it be
relevant you know it's in a sense it's
almost a badge of honor that the
references are to papers that are
incredibly recent like the last year or
so
whereas in something like physics I
would say that there's a certain
stylishness to being able to have a
reference to something that was 50 or
100 years old
something to 300 years old in physics it
would be like no that was a previous
paradigm
I think one of the things that happens
is there are Fields where there are
Paradigm boundaries like there are you
know major methodologies that get
introduced and the things that were part
of the field from before that major
methodology shift might not be so
relevant not least because the ways of
talking about things and the questions
that are asked have shifted as a result
of that change of Paradigm you know an
interesting area would be something like
AI is it the case that you know if you
look at a modern AI paper about LMS you
will find a distribution of references
from ones that are about things that
came out two weeks ago to things uh you
know referring back 50 years or more
that's an interesting case
well I think in uh for my own personal
activities uh I tend to be much more
interested in things where uh they are
in a sense they have been slow moving
and where I think I might be able to
make a contribution and the kinds of the
things that I'm building on might be 50
or 100 years old
um rather than oh I'm building on the
thing that was just done last week
that's a personal preference a lot of
the science that gets done for example
in the academic world is very much
building on things that sort of just
happened quotes last week although as I
say different fields have these
different kind of time Horizons that
that they typically adopt and I think
it's it's um uh in in terms of
some of the things that of things I've
been interested in about fundamental
Theory of physics or um things about
matter mathematics and so on it so
happens that both of those areas the the
big bursts of paradigmatic change and
activity happened about 100 years ago so
for physics it happened between about
well the very end of the 1800s and the
1920s 1930s the creation of quantum
mechanics discovery of general
relativity uh the kind of the general uh
mathematicization of studies of physics
that had begun in the 1600s but really
blossomed with things like Maxwell's
equations and so on in the later in the
mid to late 1800s
um and I think the uh so but then
that was sort of a a flowering of that
mathematical Paradigm that happened in
that period that extended up to 1920s
1930s and then after that well there's
certainly lots of great work that's been
done but it's a little it's less
Paradigm changing and I think what we're
doing now with our physics project for
example is another kind of Paradigm
changing moment where we're building
directly on sort of the last Paradigm
changing moment which was in this period
about 100 years ago in metamathamatics
the work that I've done there in uh kind
of trying to understand sort of the big
picture of metamatics what I'm calling
the physicalization of matter
mathematics again Builds on things that
happen to occur around 1900 to 1920
um I don't think there was an email I
don't know whether there was a
correlation between what was happening
in physics back in those days and what
was happening in mathematics I mean to
be clear the what happened in
mathematics was this realization that
there was an abstraction of math
mathematics itself that mathematics well
talks about abstract things but you
could sort of lift above mathematics to
say what was the meta structure of
mathematics it's about theorems and
proofs even saying that without talking
about what the content of those theorems
and proofs were so in a sense that was a
sort of a lifting up beyond the the the
actual content of mathematics to
something above that and I'm not quite
sure whether that was I don't think that
was quite what was happening in physics
at that time so I'm not sure that those
two developments were that correlated
but it so happens they were both
occurring at about the same time and in
my own efforts in recent times I've been
sort of building on on both of those
things from 100 years ago or so now
I would say that um the things you know
I'm looking at essentially the science
of llms
what's that building on well it's
building in part on incredibly recent
stuff the the you know the discoveries
made with what chat gbt is and what it
makes possible things that are sort of
you know week by week people discovering
things about scaling laws for neural
Nets and things like this that's very
recent stuff but then also
some of that science goes all the way
back to Antiquity and kinds of things
that people like Aristotle were thinking
about about what can one say about the
overall structure of language and
meaning and and things like this so at
least for me there's some rather
wonderful cases where one has both
things that are very much of the moment
and sort of discoveries being made now
bait and sort of reflecting back to
things that that date from from way
before modern science
um and I would say that some of the
things that I also find interesting some
of the things that have been revealed by
our physics project and so on about sort
of fundamental questions about how the
universe works some of those questions
haven't really been talked about during
the modern period of science so
questions like why does the universe
exist that's something where there is
work done as a sort of philosophical and
Theological level back from uh you know
a thousand years to more than that and
and maybe 500 years ago
um and but it's something that is is
those are a type of question largely
Untouched by modern science which we
start to have things to say about and I
suppose that that um one of the things
that can happen is a given Paradigm will
have certain things it can say
there may be questions that were
marooned were left behind by that
Paradigm unaddressable by that Paradigm
were marooned for 100 years 200 years
500 years and then when you come to look
at them now you're referring back to
those questions even though they kind of
missed the modern period of whatever
Paradigm is being developed so I suppose
that's a that's a case where you can
expect very long time
um uh sort of uh things to to re-emerge
but I think this whole issue of kind of
the chain of kind of intellectual
development in science
is is really an interesting one and I
would say that one of the perhaps less
than wonderful features of the Machinery
of the sort of rather industrial
Machinery of many areas of Science and
the way they're practiced in Academia is
this fact that it really is very
incremental in terms of the there are a
lot of kind of forces that push towards
having sort of incremental progress you
know you can you can get that public
paper published in the journal if it's
really similar to papers that have
already been published and it's just
adding one more little extra uh step so
to speak whereas if you're trying to go
back to a thing which was you know
really uh sort of Paradigm changing and
reflects back to earlier paradigms and
so on that's something that's much more
difficult for the industrial system to
assess and it's much less the the system
is much less less set up to deal with
something like that
um
okay there's a question here
uh
boy all sorts of questions okay one from
Aaron you talk about the history of
theories of cognition and Consciousness
what did the Ancients think what did
girdle and Turing think about this does
track gbt disprove penrose's uh
um theories about about quantum
mechanics and so on okay well I'm not
sure I've ever I've ever thought about
this history systematically before so
but let me see what I can do
um
this whole question about
the idea of consciousness
and the idea that there was
some sort of spark of something special
going on in brains that didn't happen
elsewhere was certainly a thing that
existed in antiquity
there was the idea of there being some
kind of Soul some kind of beyond the
mere mechanics of how things work
something that was more abstract more
and a seat of kind of this process of
thinking but there were some very
simplistic theories about it I mean for
example there was the idea that there
were kind of uh a pretty good idea due
to the epicureans and Democritus and
people like this that the world is just
made of a limited number of kinds of
atoms and they're atoms of different
shapes they might correspond to the
platonic solids et cetera etc etc just a
small number of them and one of them
were these fire atoms which I think was
supposed to be long and thin and so on
and that were supposed to be the the
types of atoms that represented heat but
I think they also had the idea that they
were a type of atom representing Souls
that they were a type of atom that
represented that that was kind of the
the nature of the my mind somehow was
associated with this kind of different
type of atom to be distinguished from
the atoms that would correspond to water
and things like this and I think that
the um uh that's a um
so they had this idea the the kind of
there was this sort of substance that
was the mind-like substance and it was
something like and that was kind of a a
the seat of mind so to speak that Minds
had a substance just like heat was
thought to have a substance back back at
that time well
then I think some of what this segued
into was a lot of kind of theological
religious thinking about minds and uh uh
and kind of the the nature of minds and
and what uh and kind of where did Minds
come from and where did Minds go when
the actual uh you know human or organism
died what happened to that mind-like
thing and I think the thing that was
realized pretty early was that there was
some aspect of a mind that was some kind
of uh sort of abstractly represented
thing the sort of the Eternal Soul the
abstraction of the Mind independent of
the physicality of brains and so on and
I think that was something that really
was was quite recognized that there was
something about minds that was different
from the the actual mechanics of how
brains work but how that really works
was not something that became clear
until modern times and the idea of
computation and all those kinds of
things really didn't come clear until
the last few decades I would say but
back in those days there was this kind
of notion of there's the soul-like thing
what what how does that Soul relate to
the physicality of things and so on
another issue about souls that was
loomed quite big was the question of
Free Will and the question of whether
whether somehow Minds there were was
kind of an idea that in nature there was
some regularity there were laws of
nature in some way and but then there
was kind of something where laws of
nature where things happen in the way
they have to happen in nature but then
the question was whether Minds could do
things where they just came up with that
idea and it didn't sort of mechanically
happen the way it has to happen in
nature now one confusing thing about
Antiquity is the view of fate in
Antiquity the view of of can we know
what will happen no we can't it's all
just fate and the idea that this kind of
notion that there is a Clockwork
Universe a mechanical universe that was
an idea that didn't really emerge in a
serious way I would say until the 1500
1600s kind of time frame the idea that
there that really there was one didn't
just have to oh there's fate and it can
just come and do whatever it wants there
are actual definite laws of the universe
but I think that this notion of could
there be a sort of free will a a the
mind can do anything kind of notion that
was an important notion back even
Antiquity and I think I I don't know
this history so well but I believe one
of the Innovations of Christianity was
the idea that there could be a kind of a
free will an ability to choose good or
evil or whatever else that was
independent of some Machinery provided
by the world that that was something
that was sort of an independent thing of
minds and human Minds in particular that
was something sort of separated from the
mere mechanics of the universe
I think the um
the kinds of things that uh uh well this
thinking I'm probably forgetting a lot
of philosophical and Theological work on
um uh on kind of the nature of the mind
and so on but but this whole question of
Free Will which became very entangled
with all kinds of questions about
um you know good evil uh you know how
does God make good in the world versus
how do humans choose to do bad things
Etc et cetera et cetera a lot of
discussion of that that went on from oh
basically the up until well certainly uh
well in for a long time but I mean until
um certainly hitting the the middle of
the um of the of the previous Millennium
so to speak so you know 1500 1600s
things like this
but then
there were folks like Renee Descartes
um and the late 1500s early 1600s
um who were starting to kind of think
um in a somewhat more enlightened one
might say way about kind of the nature
of the mind and those kinds of things
and Descartes famously was uh you know
how do we even know uh uh you know how
do we know that there's anything out
there all we know is what's going on
inside our minds the idea that there is
a a an actual Universe out there as
opposed to just sort of it's all in the
mind and um uh it's um and it's it's
just an internal story it's all just a a
you know a matrix like video game like
thing where we are where the sensory
where we're just a brain in a box or a
mind in a box and sensory data is being
fed to that and there isn't an outside
to the whole thing and the uh the whole
uh sort of how do we know we exist well
you know I think therefore I am type
type idea and so on but this notion of
whether there was an outside whether
there were other whether we were just
one mind in a box and there's nothing
outside and it's all just for our
benefit
um was I mean that's still an
interesting question I think it is the
main observation is that we know what's
internally happening in our minds we can
see other people and we can see that
something comparable to what we know is
happening in our mind seems to be
happening in that we their external
actions make it seem like what they're
what they're doing is something similar
to what's happening in our minds now
it's only going to get a little bit
weirder because
as we get better sensor information
about what's happening in brains you
know as I'm sitting here yakking at you
you know it could very well be the case
that at some point in the future I'll
have some display that's showing okay my
this part of my brain is lighting up and
this is happening and these these are
all the flows of of thinking that are
going on in my brain and that's what's
happening inside so to speak and when
I'm seeing somebody else I could see the
same kind of thing and it will it will
feel this idea that there's a very
different thing inside than things
outside I think that's going to Decay
because we're going to see more and more
we're going to be able to externalize
what's happening in our minds so to
speak but any case the um
the thing that um this question of kind
of what's what's going on in the mind
and uh I think I think they can't
actually made the statement that
one day we will be able to understand
what happens in a tree
just as we understand what happens in a
clock
in other words he had the idea that in
the end everything will be sort of
mechanically describable
and that was a tradition that kind of
continued
um of okay we you know science is
starting to work we're starting to be
able to have these kind of formal
descriptions of the world we're going to
get everything formalized including how
minds work and so on
well it it didn't quite quite work out
that way uh you know I think what
happened then
we're going into the um late 1800s and
things like that and uh well in the in
the 1800s there had been the beginning
of experimental psychology people like
helmholtz had worked on that
um
some other people
um the uh we're getting some of the more
famous names
um
uh William James another person but
there was this idea that there was a
science of psychology a science of
thinking you know you could have oh
things like the you know as you press as
you as you give a higher stimulus it's
sort of a logarithmic effect in certain
cases things like that the idea of kind
of noticing optical illusions the idea
of of seeing how minds work and that
that turned into people like Freud and
so on also trying to kind of make a
science of the mind and I suppose that
was sort of a a branch of this whole
kind of idea of of what became cognitive
science psychology experimental
psychology and so on a science of the
Mind
and
by 1900 or so people like Romani kajal
had done microscopy on brains and it was
kind of known that there was this kind
of wire-like mess inside brains and by
that time electrical machines were
starting to exist and it's like it's all
wires it's got electricity inside it we
can kind of see what's happening at some
level and
um uh that that became sort of a a
general motif of it's all kind of a an
electrical machine and that then segued
I suppose into things like the
cybernetics movement
um where people were like it's it's all
it's all electrical machinery and brains
and that's what's going to determine
what's happening there still was a
certain
strand I would say the the electrical
Machinery part of things which was sort
of the cybernetics world
there was then a philosophical
discussion that was then also a
religious part which was the kind of
look a soul is something very special
and you've got all these wires and so on
but you're never going to get to a soul
with a bunch of wires
and that's sort of a a piece of kind of
the that Doctrine was there something
very very special about souls and in a
sense it's true and you know in a sense
we We Now understand scientifically a
little bit more about why that's true
but
I think the um uh the thing that um
um then emerged this is probably by the
1950s there was sort of a general belief
that there was kind of like well brains
were kind of a little bit like emerging
computers and there was this kind of
philosophical theological belief that
there was something different about
minds and about inanimate matter and so
on but it was all a bit vague
I would say that going into that well
then there were things like um well the
question asked about about Alan Turing
and girdle let's talk about those those
Folk so
one of the things that had happened in
mathematics was the idea that
mathematics could become mechanical
mathematics which had been viewed as an
activity of the human mind something
which was almost an artistic kind of uh
creation activity by the time of people
like Hilbert around 1900 David Hilbert
and so on
um really trying to sort of mechanize
mathematics and say well no actually
mathematics is just this very mechanical
process of going from these axioms and
these theorems and deriving other ones
and eventually they'll sort of just be a
machine that does it there's a famous
quote uh discussion between
um Henry Point array kind of much more I
would say aesthetically oriented
mathematician and David Hilbert are much
more kind of a Machinery oriented
mathematician
um Point array I think said about
Hilbert uh it said there's a machine in
Chicago where pigs go in at one end it's
rather horrible sort of thought but is
going at one end and you know hot dogs
or hamburgers or something come out at
the other it's a giant industrial
machine and that's what Hilbert is doing
to mathematics that it's just like it's
going to be a machine where axioms go in
at one end and all the theorems of
mathematics come out at the other end
there's no room for a mind there's no
room for something beyond the mere
mechanical
girdle didn't believe that girdle was in
some ways a sort of I would say a very
much more uh Soul Humanity oriented kind
of thinker who who really did think
there was something sort of in the mind
that was beyond the merely mechanical
and what um uh when he proved girdle's
theorem in 1931 one of his goals was to
blow up this whole idea that mathematics
was a mechanically accessible thing and
his idea was something where there is a
a kind of there is something about minds
that is is somehow doing more than the
mere mechanical now now one thing that I
think girdle also thought was in a in a
in the Plato tradition of there is a
thing that is mathematics and
mathematicians are merely discovering
pieces of the thing of the actual sort
of reality that is out there that is
mathematics very different from Hilbert
who said we can just construct
mathematics we can put in we can talk
about tables and chairs we can talk
about rings and Fields it doesn't matter
we are constructing mathematics as a
purely synthetic activity from its kind
of axiomatic basis
um the girdle thought mathematics was
really a thing that already existed in
in some platonic sense and we as minds
and so on are merely exploring pieces of
it and the the sort of the role of the
Mind somehow is is to decide what to
explore
and for example even in when he wrote up
girdle's theorem he has some uh
statement where he says well you know it
could be that this mechanical way of
doing mathematics can only get to
certain things and Minds might go much
further than that uh he has a weird
quote about uh ramified theory of types
into the trans-finite as a a kind of a
what might Minds be beyond the mere
hilbertian kind of machinery
well so so that's what girdle thought
and I think in modern times in my own
physicalization of metamatics
um the uh uh what we've sort of realized
is that yes that's really true there is
a real thing out there it is this
rouliad object the entangled limit of
all possible computations and when we do
mathematics girl was right we're just
sampling as humans in our human way
we're sampling little slices of that and
that really ad object which is the
underlying thing of metamathamatics is
the same thing that is the underlying
thing of a physical universe and insofar
as we claim the physical Universe exists
we also must claim that the underlying
thing of mathematics suggests and we are
merely seeing parts of it
but let's come to Turing so Turing
had originally in his conception of a
turing machine he wanted to find he was
really trying to find an idealization of
what mathematics is
in the same way that Hilbert had done
and Whitehead and Russell had done and
so on but Turing wanted to make it more
mechanical he wanted to really nail that
down and his original model was to think
about well how Bank clerks you know take
things out of files and and write
numbers down and erase other numbers
because they don't do that anymore
because they're using computers now but
but back in the day that's what they
would do with with you know pieces of
paper and pencils and all that kind of
thing
and and so
that was his kind of model of what what
computation might be and he idealized
that in 1936 as his turing machine idea
and then
I think he didn't really he just thought
of that as a model for kind of how
mathematical Machinery works
the idea that that might be a model that
went beyond that it might be modeled
Minds it might be a model even a physics
he didn't get to the it might be a model
of physics he thought that Turing
machines were at best something that was
a model of mental processes the idea
that things like Turing machines and and
the computation as defined by by folks
like Turing might be something that is a
matter of relevance to the natural world
to physics I think probably I might be
the person who who pushed that idea more
seriously than anybody else in the 1980s
actually because for a long time people
have believed well there's computation
that involves discreet things and all
that kind of thing and then there's
physics and it's all based on the
differential equations that have been
vented in the 1600s and physics is not
something that can be talked about
discreetly in that way and that was
something in the in the 1980s I kind of
pushed the idea that these these Notions
of computation are very useful for
understanding the physical world even
though at that time I didn't know and
didn't didn't have a reason to believe
that physics would turn out to be
computational really all the way down
but at least as a as a way of describing
as a way of modeling things in in
Natural Science computation was clearly
useful alongside the equations and
things like this what we now believe as
a result of our physics project is that
yes the universe actually is
computational all the way down so that
really is is much more set on Bedrock
than it was at that time but so Turing
didn't didn't get that far he didn't
think that his Turing machines were
relevant to physics by 1950 or so he did
think they were relevant to mines and he
did start talking about kind of this
idea you know the touring tests and all
that kind of thing came from that period
of time when he'd gotten to the point of
saying this this mechanical construction
thing seems to be capturing what's
really happening in Minds
now if we go further than that and we
ask uh kind of how did that evolve how
did this idea that there could be a sort
of a a mind-like thing that was uh
mechanically producible AI uh that term
arose in the mid-1950s with uh Marvin
Minsky John McCarthy
um these folk in the MIT kind of uh uh
computer-ish orbit so to speak that was
where that came from and it was sort of
also very much tied in with the
cybernetics movement that had come out
of wiener also an MIT person
um from uh from the 1930s and 1940s and
so on but that was a tradition that sort
of AI and its relationship to
Consciousness cognition these kinds of
things they were not that seriously
connected I mean there was Ai and AI
went through periods like in the 19
early 1960s where it's like well
actually in the 1950s people were like
computers are going to make artificial
social Brains it's just a done deal
then by the 1960s it was like well we're
going to do these great projects like
we're going to invent automated language
translation we're going to have machines
that can go around do planning and walk
around like robots and so on and they're
kept on being it's going to work it's
going to work it didn't work and so by
the 1970s there was kind of a a uh well
there was a a sort of a a no AI isn't
going to work then the 1980s were expert
systems and so on there were a series of
waves of this
um and I think but I think the the idea
that anybody would be serious about
saying we've nailed down how brains work
and it's just like these AIS we've got
nobody really took that that seriously I
think what is has been progressively
shocking so to speak is that a lot of
things where people said as soon as we
can get a machine to do X then it's
going to be a true Ai and one of the
last really big boundaries is when we
can get a machine to kind of Converse a
natural language that was kind of the
Turing test idea from 1950 then we'll
know we've really got Ai and that's
what's happened this year
and I think that the you know what we
learn from what's happened there is well
it is just a neural net and it's doing a
pretty good job of generating you know
human-like natural language and that
means when we look at brains and we say
what's really going on in brains is it
weird and Quantum and molecular and so
on or is it just a bunch of wires
basically with a bunch of neurons
there's a lot of evidence now it's just
a bunch of wires with a bunch of neurons
and so for example people like Roger
Penrose uh who is I think very much in
this kind of um almost I wouldn't say
I wouldn't it wouldn't be fair to quite
mystical tradition but very much in the
girdle kind of there's something more
going on than the mere mechanical and
physical
um has has been interested I think in
looking for kind of ways that uh that
brains go beyond the mere mechanical
kind of uh clunking along of neural Nets
and looking for that in terms of quantum
gravity and things like this and looking
for the possibility that there is some
effect beyond the physics we know beyond
the mechanisms we know that can
contribute something special to brains
and yes I think that now there's a lot
of evidence against that from the
success of of chat gbt and so on
um now I will say that the um uh
um what is it objective reduction is
that the term there's there's this
question that arises in quantum
mechanics of sort of the big deal of
quantum mechanics well in our models of
physics now I think I'm finally getting
to the point where I can say I really
understand quantum mechanics
um it's all about this fact that there
are many possible histories for the
universe that Branch they merge this is
this kind of idea when we look at a
slice across all these histories we get
this kind of branchial space of possible
branches of History
um but and and we when we're observing
the universe we our minds are in a sense
also branching and merging and we are
extended in branchial space
so this question about a sort of
objective reduction
um is the question of whether somehow
there is a necessary channeling of all
these different branches of History
crushed down into one branch because
because we believe that definite things
happen in the universe and I think we
believe that because we're actually
spanning many branches of history and we
just in the way that we think things
happen in the world are conflating all
these different branches of history but
there's a different possibility which is
what I think Roger Penrose not sure that
you know is quite this is what he's
doing and I've been minute to point this
out to him but but
um the uh the the thing that
is really quite interesting is in in
physical space we're used to the idea of
black holes where there's a big lump of
mass and energy and that causes a great
you know enough gravity that we get a
black hole and uh sort of everything is
kind of uh everything's flow into the
black hole and nothing flows out of the
black hole and the black hole is this
kind of unique place where for example
time can end and sort of one is in a
situation where a sort of things go in
and then everything stops
well in bronchial space you can have the
analog of black holes as well we don't
yet quite know how those work but I
think that's what objective reality
reduction
um is is about it is about the the skull
The Singularity that can happen in
branchial space where these many threads
of History all are sort of sucked
together into this one Singularity and
and interestingly enough Roger Pano is
one of his his achievements is this
so-called Singularity theorems which say
that there is inevitability to the
formation of a black hole when there's
enough energy momentum in a particular
region of space and you get these sort
of Trapped surfaces where light can't
escape and so on it inevitably forms
form singularities and no doubt the same
thing is true in branchial space and no
doubt that same kind of Singularity idea
would lead to this notion of crushing
down to a single state but I'm not sure
that that's what happens I don't think
that's an important effect of brains
you know I think it's it's a funny thing
because you know I've been interacting
with some philosophers and you know lots
of techies about Ai and things like this
and it's still
uh kind of the philosophy and the and
the science definitely are not all on
the same page yet
I think that there's still a uh uh the
sort of the discourse on the
philosophical side continues to be as it
has been for thousands of years
continues to be very much at the kind of
uh we can give an argument with words
kind of level on the on the sort of the
AI techie side it's like well we put a
bunch of neurons into this thing and
suddenly it starts producing text and we
don't really know narratively how that
works so there's really a disconnect
between these two worlds of the kind of
the narrative description and philosophy
where you can make an argument with
words and the kind of and we made a you
know 100 billion neurons and it did
something interesting but we don't
really know we don't have a bigger
picture about why that's happening and I
think that's a an important piece of
what one might call sort of llm science
that is an emerging possibility for the
next few years to bring those things
together to be able to take this sort of
what has been described in words
philosophically and on the other side
look at kind of the the actual mechanics
of what's going on the physics of of
thought so to speak
I would say also that when it comes to
psychology I mean that these different
levels there's sort of a psychology of
the phenomenology of how brains work and
how people do things and so on and then
there's the neuroscience
going down to the level of how
individual neurons fire and it's been a
big mystery in Neuroscience what's the
kind of Intermediate Language of
Neuroscience the description that is
above the level of individual neurons
and below the level of psychology well
we have the same issue now with llms
we've got the low-level description of
we can look at the individual neurons
and so on and we've got the high level
and it talks to us more or less and we
still don't have that intermediate layer
knowing what that intermediate layer is
like will probably give us a great
science of Neuroscience it will probably
also give us some interesting insights
about psychology it will probably also
give us important insights about Ai and
so on and you know who knows what the uh
what the Mind hack that turns out to be
the great thing you can do in prompt
engineering for a chat GPT or something
will be but that's something that can
come out of that kind of science
let's see
oh my lots of interesting questions here
oh boy
um
eigen is asking about Aristotle leibniz
girdle people like me
um How was
were people able to understand the idea
of universal computation what reach that
Insight that's a very interesting
historical question so you know
Universal computation the idea that
things can be programmable that you can
have one machine that can do all these
different kinds of computations
that's an idea that I feel is sort of a
an idea that happened in the 1920s and
1930s and it's bizarre that it didn't
happen earlier and it is a lesson to us
in in the kinds of things that the kinds
of thoughts we cannot form because we
just don't have the right paradigms and
it's kind of a lesson to us today what
things are we not understanding today
which will seem utterly obvious in the
future
because
the fact is uh you know Aristotle could
he have understood the idea of universal
computation could he have understood the
idea that there can be a description
so one of the key things is this notion
that code and data can be the same thing
that the data the things the the sort of
the the the dead facts of something can
also represent code can also be
instructions for doing things
so the question would be I mean what
would what would Aristotle said that
could have led to something like that he
could have said
that
the yeah actually he could have had a a
way of thinking about this
um
Let me Give an example so from the early
days of
well I don't think Aristotle quite had
this but for example Panini and the
Sanskrit tradition had this idea of
writing down sort of a descriptive
grammar of Sanskrit
and which sort of was it's a little bit
hard to understand and I'm not
completely sure we're not back
projecting some things from modern times
but in some sense it was kind of a this
is how you make Sanskrit sentences it is
a procedure it is written in Sanskrit
but it describes how to make Sanskrit
and that's a little bit close to a
universal computer it is something which
is written in the data of that the
computer manipulates but it is saying
how the computer can do things
so could Aristotle have had that idea of
saying we can write a description of
what we do and it is written in the same
terms as the thing that we produce as
our output I mean in some sense uh well
okay so that was a that was a thing now
now something that I think Aristotle did
understand was
um this idea of the equivalence of human
languages it is not self-evident that it
is possible to translate from one human
language to another and that the same
abstract thoughts can be expressed in
different languages and and there's
still argument about and it isn't even
the case that you know there is a bit of
a difference in complexion between the
thoughts that can be expressed in one
language and another that's a whole
different thing I think we understand
that much better in terms of thinking
about rule spaces and all these kinds of
things but but you know this notion of
interconvertibility between languages
that was something which was understood
in Antiquity and again another hint
towards Universal computation
leibniz
um mid to late 1600s he got a lot closer
uh that was I mean there was a kind of a
well this idea that there could be a
representation of thought a concretified
representation of thought
there were other people who talked about
that Ramon Lull in the 1200s a Catalan
thinker had this very bizarre uh kind of
way of of having the sort of somewhat
mystical kind of um uh sort of things he
would write out which would be kind of
like things for constructing sentences
you know it's kind of like a Mad Lib
type thing where you have you know a few
words and another word then another word
and it's kind of a construction kit for
sentences it's almost like he thought of
it I think as a construction kit for
thought
well again it's it's going towards the
data is code data is thought leibniz
same kind of idea
um he was an enthusiastic I think and he
got to the point of having this notion
of a characteristica universalis some
kind of logical language you know about
logic
um that some kind of logic language sort
of mathematical like description that
could talk about everything and that
again got closer to the idea of you can
talk about everything in some kind of uh
form that is sort of concrete and
specific and yet it can talk about
everything and and that's again a kind
of a complexion of universal computation
now in I think the the this in at the
time of Hilbert and the sort of the
flowering of mathematics around 1900 and
so on then there was well in mathematics
we will have this framework this meta
model of mathematics which can talk
about any conceivable mathematics that
became another much more concrete way in
which one might have a single framework
that could talk about everything
well there were some attempts at that
framework with primitive recursive
functions things like that that didn't
work out
then in 1920 Moses Sean Finkel came up
with combinators which as we now know
are in fact Universal in that sense and
the uh then uh Emerald post came up with
post systems then girdle came up with
General recursive functions Alonzo
church with Lambda calculus Alan touring
with Turing machines
all of these were descriptions which
went from a a single kind of descriptive
framework to kind of the implication
that it might cover all of mathematics
nobody was sure it would nobody knew
that for sure it was all a hypothesis on
the part of all those folk and one of
the big discoveries was all those
different hypotheses about what might
describe mathematics in general turned
out to be equivalent and that's a big
clue and then this notion that that well
with with touring the thing became sort
of more concrete and when when Moore got
the idea of a machine that was
programmable and so on and that's that's
where this kind of uh that's where this
started to emerge from the notion that
that might extend to the natural world
as I say that was a notion that really
took until the 1980s
um and was very much firmly I I can even
say in the 1980s even into the early
2000s it was a thing that was widely not
believed and uh uh you know I think at
this point we're we're getting to the
point where yeah that really is the way
things things work and have to work and
it is in a sense remarkable that this
particular idea of universal computation
that emerged both from mathematics and
then from almost the thinking about
Machinery that Turing did that that
turns out to be something that's
relevant to the to the natural world
let's see
uh
Aryan is asking about Von Neumann John
Von Neumann and his uh work to
understand models of computation in the
mind you know Von Neiman's last book was
this thing called the computer in the
brain
um
which
I think Von Neumann was an optimist and
an Enthusiast and said you know we've
got brains we've got computers computers
are going to be like brains and in fact
his understanding of how to make a
practical electronic computer
he was kind of borrowing from McCulloch
and pits and their work on neural Nets
from 1943 and they in turn were
borrowing from Alan Turing the idea of
universal computation and the idea that
one could get a a a neural net to do the
same things the touring with Gene could
do and to do sort of arbitrary
computation and that's actually I think
how Von Neumann even he he knew of
touring the person but he didn't
understand touring machines until he
kind of went through that back route
through neural Nets and the final I mean
Von Neumann was
uh you know I would say he
had a lot of ideas about what will be
important for example he was very
concerned about reliability of
components how could you make a big
electronic computer or a big brain that
all these components in it even when
some of those components might fail why
did that not cause the brain to just
freeze up or the computer to just freeze
up he was very concerned about issues
like that that turn out to be kind of a
non-issue and the uh the things that um
you know I'm not sure
that I would say and maybe I'm being
unfair here trying to remember what's in
the computer in the brain it's a little
thin book of based on some lectures he
gave at Yale
um and he wrote it when he was very much
uh dying of of um uh nasty cancer
um at the age of like 53 or so
um and I think that the um
uh he um
um I'm not sure quite what he
contributed to that whole discussion
except that he did the very the the
important sort of piece of Arc of
intellectual history of of merging sort
of through McCulloch and pits and neural
Nets merging kind of the turing machine
story Into the practicality of actual
electronic computers that were being
built
let's see
um
oh boy so many interesting questions
here you guys um
uh
um
well Jamie is asking how's the
importance of areas of science shifted
in history what was the main focus of
science 500 years ago 100 years ago 10
years ago
you know science progresses
by sort of the invention of new
methodologies which then open up new
areas very energetic things happen you
know whether that was chemistry in the
late 1800s we can make all these
chemical compounds to physics in the
beginning of the 1900s of we've got all
these mathematical methods we can do all
these kinds of things two computer
science in the 1970s and 1980s 1990s
we've got all these algorithms we can
make two kind of things about AI where
we didn't know it was going to work but
now we have this kind of large language
model thing what what keeps on happening
is there are these kind of
methodological advances things open up
very intense activity for a short period
of time then that kind of area becomes
much more standardized and moves forward
what can happen
I think what drives science more than
another thing is these moments of
methodological Advance which are
sometimes a matter of experimental
method sometimes a matter of matter of a
new way of thinking about things a sort
of paradigmatic change those are the
things that ultimately are the big
things that drive science forward
and they happen rarely and when they
happen they often happen in a way that
defines a new science
and uh you know I wrote this big book
called the new kind of science 20 years
ago now 21 years ago actually and next
week
um the uh uh which was an attempt to
kind of Define a new kind of science
based on sort of computation as a core
way of thinking about things and that's
an example of kind of a paradigmatic
change
um of the kind that's happened a bunch
of times in the history of Science and I
think that the uh uh this is you know
it's very hard to predict these
paradigmatic changes but they often
Define they're not they're off sometimes
they are we've got an existing science
we know what it's talking about and boom
there's a new method there's a new
experimental method there's a new
theoretical method and the existing kind
of content area of that science suddenly
wakes up and exciting things happen
there but sometimes the subject matter
is different
you know in thinking about LM science
for example the subject matter of that
science is really going to be different
it's not going to be psychology it's not
going to be computer science it's not
going to be physics it's going to be a
different kind of thing and that's uh
you know that's a that's a way that
advances happen now when you say what
kind of science was done well not all
the sciences that we have today even had
a name they weren't even a thing one
thought about computer science wasn't a
thing one thought about 100 years ago it
wasn't a defined kind of a thing
and you know that's something you know
that that's that's what happens with the
methodological advances is sort of new
areas get opened up that become new
Sciences now I would say that that um
the other thing that happens is the
application of the Science and
Technology there are areas of science
that get sort of enmeshed with
technology and that's a major driver for
sort of more development in those areas
and that's I think something that um
well we see in some kinds of things we
don't see in other kinds of things we
see there are areas of physics that have
become enmesh with technology and are
really zooming forward like condensed
matter physics for example there is a
physics that have not gotten a mesh with
technology like particle physics which
have a different kind of uh a different
kind of story to them so you know what
um uh the focus of science
you know worth remembering 500 years ago
uh well let's see we would yeah a little
bit more than 500 years ago was
Copernicus
and that was a key moment in science
because there had been this question of
was science just natural philosophy was
it a matter of debate was it a we can
just use our senses and debate what's
going on or was there some sort of
formal Tower where you could say well I
got this calculations and they show that
the Earth can be going around the Sun
and so on and even though that doesn't
seem to be our common experience and
even though by pure sort of human
argumentation we couldn't we wouldn't
conclude that then there was this notion
that there is an abstract formal method
that concludes that that's a possibility
absent you know different from our kind
of everyday way of thinking about things
so that was sort of a major change I
think there's a similar change
computation is another such change I
mean I think the the notion of
kind of the the intuition of computation
and things like computational
irreducibility and so on they are a very
um
there's sort of a a major change in the
way that one thinks about thinking about
things so to speak just as Copernicus
was a major change in the way one
thought about thinking about things from
we can just argue it out to there are
formal facts about the world which are
not amenable which are not immediately
accessible to kind of our everyday
experience
um
well let's see there's so many questions
here Paula is asking is there a
connection between these advances to
science and education does education
evolve with these changes
well sadly not really I mean education
look the the
we're still in kind of early days for
very widespread public education early
days 150 years 120 years the depends on
what part of the world you're in but a
hundred and a bit years most in many
places
and you know there's been a sort of
definition of what is the thing to
communicate in education now if we go
back even to Antiquity there was a
certain set of subject matter Aristotle
really was the person who who more than
anybody sort of captured the list of
these are the things you should learn I
mean some of what he said was totally
Goofy from Modern but modern point of
view but he was sort of the
encyclopedist of the time it's just go
read the encyclopedia it's kind of by
the time you've got the encyclopedia and
the Bible or your analog of that you're
kind of your set or what you have to
learn those are those are the things so
to speak and I think the uh uh education
moves
kind of shockingly slowly in many ways
and in a sense education should be and
is about you know we have a human
society and the you know when born we
don't know how to operate in that human
society and particularly as Society has
gotten more and more sophisticated in
all sorts of ways we have to kind of be
be taught it's the way our species has
evolved we have to be taught how to
operate in human society and so on and
in a sense education is kind of this
normalizing Force that's like okay
everybody you know in place X you know
all kind of learn the same way to
operate in human society and people can
get very upset about oh you don't want
everybody to think the same way or you
you know and and in fact of course that
isn't in Contra in contradiction to the
idea that we want new stuff to happen
because if we get everybody thinking the
same way so they can all operate in the
same society and sort of live happily
with each other and all that kind of
thing then you're kind kind of driving
something towards alignment parallelism
and thinking but yet if you want new
things to happen better be the case that
somebody says oh I can think outside of
that box and that's in a sense one of
the paradoxes of Education it is both
useful to align and useful to allow a
lack of alignment I think that that
hasn't gone that well the um and I think
as we see kind of more pressure on the
importance of Education in sort of the
uh at least in the sort of uh some some
parts of society so to speak there's
much more of you've got to run down this
race track to get to the other end and
the only way you're going to get down
the race track is to go straight in that
in that straight line and the idea that
there may be other things you could look
at on other sides is something you've
got to ignore because you've got to get
to the end of the race track so to speak
so I think um the uh
the thing that um uh you know what we
need to see and what we can see is a
change in education but boy is that a
difficult thing to achieve I think the
very exciting thing that kind of llms
have brought to us is a possibility of
total broadening of access to this
computational Paradigm it isn't just
going to be the sort of high Priests of
of programming and things that have
access and this has been my lifelong
effort of mine is to try and kind of
broaden out the access to this very
powerful idea and Technology of
computation and I think that llms help
in that broadening process in a in a
fairly important way and it's like what
is post llm education what is it like we
don't know yet I'm thinking about it I
think it's very interesting question
there are things that uh very suddenly
uh don't need to be taught the way they
they were taught there's much more
possibility for personalization there's
much more possibility for you don't
really need to learn that but you can
just ask the machine to do it that's
been a thing that's happened I myself
have been responsible for some of those
some of those changes in a bunch of
areas of kind of more mathematical
quantitative kinds of things that you
don't have to do that integral by hand a
machine can do it for you type thing
um and it's kind of the the progress of
of society of civilization and Tech you
know is is really is measured in part in
the progress of Technology what can we
automate what can we not have to do
ourselves what can we just take to the
point where we have to figure out what
we should want to do but then where it
can automatically get done and then to
what extent do we need to know sort of
how the car works and how much do we
just need to know how to drive the car
and I think we're seeing another great
moment of we just need to know how to
drive the car we don't have to know how
to you know how it works inside we don't
have to you know spend every time we're
going to go on a drive opening up the uh
the engine and you know re rearranging
wires and so on we don't have to do that
we can just get in the car you know
switch it on and start driving kind of
thing and that's the thing that
increasingly we're able to do with
computation and that's a thing which we
should be teaching future Generations
how to do because that is the that's the
place where we both it is a much broader
thing to teach it is a much less you
know if you don't happen to have a mind
that's well oriented towards the the
detailed Machinery of of programming
languages and so on it doesn't really
matter anymore it's something where if
you have the ability to think in general
you're you're coming out ahead you don't
need the specifics of oh I need to know
this very formal detailed technical
thing so I think it's uh it's an
exciting moment
um it will be interesting to see how
that Evolution takes place
um I have to say my observation over the
last 40 years or so of sort of the ways
of education is that it's awfully slow
moving and there are so many forces that
in part serve this other need of
Education of sort of keep everybody
aligned
um which is something that almost by
definition
um has to be a kind of slow moving
activity
let's see maybe a couple more questions
and then I should um uh
um
Move Along here let me see
Katie asks what's been the most
important invention that has improved
research overall
well there have been a bunch of things
I think
in the
I would like to think that computation
as a paradigm for describing things and
as a way of automating things has had a
contribution I would say it's had more
of a contribution in terms of the
practicality of automating what was done
by hand before then it has yet had in
terms of a way of describing things you
know as mathematical notation had this
way of crispening up how to describe
things mathematically 500 years ago or
so now so computation at least my
efforts in sort of computational
language are a way to kind of Crispen up
the way to think about things
computationally that has happened to
some extent but there is a big tsunami
of activity that will happen in the
future on that as people really realize
how to start formulating everything in
computational language terms hasn't
quite happened hasn't the wave hasn't
really quite come through yet on that
and it's more been the practicality of
using computer to do things now there
are other pieces the uh the fact that
sort of communication of scientific
information is a bit faster it's a bit
cheaper it's you know back in the day
there were you know when I started doing
science
it was a question you know there were
journals and they got mailed to places
you go to the library and you look at
them and then there were pre-prints and
they got mailed to places and you went
to the library and you look at them or
sometimes you've got them in your own
mailbox physical mailbox that is
um and uh and then even at that time but
you know in the 1970s there were already
online abstract Services where you could
uh go and and dial up to this thing and
you could um well once you had access to
a computer you could uh go and you could
start searching abstracts and things
very much like what you would do in a
modern search engine but just abstract
scientific abstracts for some bizarre
reason Only The Druids used it and by
Druids here I mean Librarians you know
people would go to reference Librarians
and say can you look this up for me and
I I realized around I don't know 1978
1979 wait a minute it's just some system
you just log into the thing and you go
and look it up yourself off and it has a
slightly Arcane syntax but it's not not
that Arcane and so you know I got myself
an account and and you know you could go
off and you'd start logging these things
up and a lot of things I discovered in
the well early 1980s you know I was able
to look up all these references online
um and I I'm not sure if I'd had to go
through the sort of extra layer of
librarians and things would have been
much more difficult I mean this whole
thing about being able to do
computations yourself as opposed to
going through a loop of having a
computation expert doing them that's
been important I would like to think
that our Mathematica system that came
out in 1988 I would say it was actually
fairly dramatic that it really went from
the point where theoretical and
mathematical scientists always had to
have a programmer in the loop kind of
dealing with that nasty oily machine so
to speak to the point where they could
with their own fingers cause a
computation to happen that was that was
a big thing I mean for me you know my
whole sort of story of doing research
research has been using computers as
tools it's always surprised me that that
tool use wasn't as extensive in the
world of science as it might have been I
think
in uh this kind of ready access to uh to
information that the web has provided
and that the conventions around the web
have provided is also important
um I think that one thing that is true
today that wasn't true in the past you
know even when I was working on my book
new kind of Science in the 1990s to know
that I knew everything about or not
everything but to know that I'd really
dug to the bottom of some particular
question and really you know mind out
the history of some particular thing
that was quite hard to do that required
serious Library work and so on and often
talking to lots of people it's much
easier today to know does the world know
anything about this okay I'll search the
web I'll go look here I'll go look there
it's much easier to get to the bottom of
those things and that's I think an
important important development I think
that um the idea of having clear
expositions I think are math World
system was a good first example of that
Wikipedia kind have based a bunch of
things on mathworld
um as a kind of let's just say what
there is to say as opposed to the kind
of more slightly more ornate style of
textbooks that had existed in the past
that's another thing that that's
definitely helped in terms of you know
just tell me the facts type thing and
you know I would say in terms of
let's see I was I was going to um
um
this
whole
well
the the kind of there's been both good
news and bad news about the decreasing
cost of putting sort of scientific
material out into the world the research
material out into the world the good
news is uh it's more stuff is getting
out there the bad news is more stuff is
getting out there and it drowns and
things things there had to be these
whole systems built that in a sense are
systems that are built for the average
they're you know when there's something
really surprising that comes out there
the systems that are like oh we've got
the uh you know the kind of the physics
you know system that is dealing with the
stuff that normally happens in physics
and the 50 000 200 000 whatever papers
that come out about this kind of thing
we've got the thing that handles the 200
000 papers when the one really Paradigm
changing paper comes out it's like oh my
gosh we don't have a way to deal with
this partly because there were two
hundred thousand other papers at a time
when science was much smaller that was a
different story look in terms of of
other things with research another area
that is still as yet just bubbling up is
automated data taking
the fact that you know instead of the
person writing it in a lab notebook it's
a heavily automated system there's a
lovely one based on modern language that
Emerald Cloud lab has built for for
biology and chemistry of of just
automating kind of doing those
experiments and again that Revolution is
just at the at the threshold of
happening of being able to go from from
something where it's kind of like the
description of the experiment to the
doing of the experiment and taking the
data automatically and and having that
all be part of sort of this
computational process that's a that's a
thing that's I would say just emerging
now
um you know I think one of the things
about research and the rhythm of
research is is this that that there are
times when there's a uh a kind of a
um a sort of
an ability to absorb new ideas and
there's a time when it's really hard for
new ideas to emerge and usually in these
periods of time when fields are just
sort of making incremental progress
they're going okay they didn't get stuck
but they didn't have a big burst of
paradigmatic progress in those times
it's pretty hard to insert new ideas
takes a lot of effort
um at times when Fields have kind of
gotten to the point where oh my gosh
we're stuck
that's okay you can inject a new idea or
at times when everybody knows there are
new ideas in the air that's another time
when one can inject those things so kind
of what makes research sort of happen
and be be energetic is often being in
one of those periods for some particular
area
let's see
um
yeah rock is commenting in 1991 there's
a system called Eric which was indeed a
um uh
an early
um
uh online system and uh
yes
good example
um let me see maybe one more thing here
um
oh
okay let's try
um I've got two more I think I'll look
at uh one from OBS historically what
have been the most difficult problems or
obstacles for us to overcome or solve in
areas of Science and Technology
I think my answer to that is
sort of the development of new paradigms
new ways of thinking about things
that tends to be the blocker
and it's often those new ways of
thinking about things Define what
questions one should ask
and if you don't know what questions to
ask you can't get even get started if
you don't know you know we could have
invented
lots of stuff about theoretical
computation long before there were
computers
doesn't require computers it's abstract
conceptual kinds of things but until
they were computers and until we had
this Paradigm of thinking about
computation which came from the
technology of computers mostly we just
didn't get to ask those questions so I
think that this I this question of
what's the framework in which we're
thinking about things which defines what
kinds of questions we might ask that
tends to be a big blocker and it really
until those that emerges we just can't
make forward progress more so than where
the question is in sight and we just
don't know how to answer it now there
are areas where we have that for example
in biomedicine there are plenty of areas
you know can we cure cancer can we you
know prevent aging can we do these kinds
of things we would like to do those
questions are absolutely in sight
um which is uh and we kind of know the
definition now now sometimes those
questions when we peel them apart a
little bit more they become a little bit
it becomes a a little bit less clear the
question really is in sight
um you know like like I don't know
something about aging you might say well
what really is aging what is the you
know is it telomeres dropping off is it
oxidation or you know oxidative damage
is it this is that you know what really
is it you know you want to cure it but
what really is it you know we have an
intuitive sense of what it is but if we
want to you know we need kind of a way
to think about it that allows us to
Define it better so that we have a
chance to sort of attack it in a
scientific point of view so I think as I
say I think that that tends to be the
the issue and then technology as well
it is often a what's the right question
to ask it's like I don't know a social
network you know the concept of those
could have been invented that the the
raw material for them could have existed
quite a long time before they actually
became a thing but it was kind of the
idea that that would be a thing that was
worth having was an important step that
was sort of a paradigmatic step and uh
uh you know that this is the the
conceptualization of what what is worth
doing is and is important piece and that
I think tends to be the biggest blocker
you know it's it's now again there are
counter examples you know one could have
said Okay a good example with the whole
chat GPT thing you could have said yes
we want a system that can you know
resolve that can pass the Turing test it
can generate natural language it can
have conversations people have been kind
of science fictionally talking about
that for a very long time
I think the precise definition of what
should it do I mean I didn't quite have
that it was all a bit vague well it's
kind of Turing tests like things but we
don't really know how it would work and
I know I for example had not really
conceptualized that a text completion
system when it worked well enough would
be able to pass the Turing test
basically and and that was a thing that
that again the the if if one had known
the sort of precise definition of given
a prompt can you continue you know if
one had really conceptualized that one
probably could have quote solved this
problem maybe
um it was uh the the but that was a case
where curiously the technological
methodology Advanced ahead of the
conceptual side of things that ahead of
the kind of and this is how it will work
and why it will be useful and and we can
now we're now kind of it was it was a
case where sort of a surprise uh sort of
uh scientific technological Discovery
happen and that then goes the one to
think about it I mean I suppose there
are plenty of others where there was
sort of surprises I don't think anybody
expected x-rays for example back around
the late the end of the 1800s and so on
and that led to a whole level of other
kinds of things being being studied and
so on so occasionally these things
happen
um and uh kind of you know the surprise
Discovery gets made sort of independent
of paradigm
um all right one more uh
well okay Pedro is asking about
unintended consequences of revolutions
what lessons from the Industrial
Revolution have we learned that we could
use for the AI Revolution
oh boy you guys don't ask simple
questions
um
what what happened in the industrial
revolution well
you know there were things the concept
that you could have machinery
and production lines and so on
eventually that would take over from the
individuals doing things for themselves
the centralization of production
um I think that that was a I mean
already there had been plenty of kind of
you know you have the particular
Tradesmen doing this it wasn't everybody
wasn't a blacksmith you went to the
specialized blacksmith to have the the
Horseshoes put on or whatever
um as opposed to just everybody as their
own blacksmith but then this idea that
that one could kind of
um go from
sort of individual human effort to this
machinery and so on I suppose what were
the some consequences of that I think
some of the unintended consequences were
a different way of thinking about things
the concept that you could make things
industrial that you could have kind of
this this thing which became a
production line I think that led to a
bunch of thinking about education about
political systems about these kinds of
things I think that was quite unexpected
I don't think anybody could have
expected that this idea of let us make
kind of the organization of countries as
organized as a production line was a
thing that would come out from this kind
of Machinery the the
um that was made in the industrial
revolution I think another thing that uh
the whole structure of society and the
notion of uh uh kind of the
centralization of of kind of industry
and so on that's another thing I mean
there have been a centralization of
governments with monarchies and things
like that the centralization of the
industrial of the process of manufacture
with kind of the the quotes captains of
industry type thing that was a thing
that was sort of new at that time and I
guess was a I'm not sure anybody really
expected that I think also the kind of
whole structure of their towns there's
there's you know you can you can have
this whole sort of centralization of
Labor of people kind of coming to the
site of the industrial stuff as opposed
to everybody has their own
um you know everybody has their own
equipment out on their own Farm type
thing that's another thing sort of the
centralization of that
so a good question what does this you
know what can we learn in the AI World
well okay I hear a few things I think
so one of the things I think is going to
emerge is the concentration on
specialization in education this kind of
idea that you should sort of the best
thing to learn is the specialized Tower
of knowledge in some particular area my
guess is that it will become clearer
that that isn't a good idea just as back
at the at the time of sort of the
Industrial Revolution the exact opposite
happened you know it was the case you
were operating your farm and you kind of
had to do everything and then well
actually no I was just you know working
on a production line and just had to do
this one one thing as a very specialized
thing my guess is that will reverse and
that the value put on General thinking
and general knowledge will increase
greatly and and that's a so that's
perhaps a one unintended consequence I
think that the the kind of the question
of sort of who has access
to the most powerful tools so to speak
uh what has happened in the industrial
revolution and and following that all
the things that happen with the sort of
growth of computation and and kind of
the the tech technology is that the
people who really quotes understand
what's going on it becomes a smaller and
smaller group of people
and yes it is I mean in a sense it's
kind of ironic because at some level you
know with something like chat GPT nobody
understands what's going on you know I
wrote this book about what's Chachi PT
doing and why does it work and arguably
I you know I have probably a better
understanding than the average
um of of of kind of how it works
um but I wouldn't say I quote understand
how it works it's a you know I know the
mechanics of what it's doing and I have
some ideas about the sort of bigger
picture of what it's doing but it isn't
the case that it's like I you know I
kind of can be an engineer who's
adjusting this one valve inside the
thing and I know it's going to do as a
result of that
um so in a sense we've gotten to the
point where for a while it was like only
a few people understood the Machinery
too like nobody really understands the
machinery and we're all in the same boat
and that in a sense makes it a thing
that is uh
is kind of a um uh I think that's an
interesting moment because it really
flattens out the uh uh sort of the
access to this kind of the the ability
to really leverage this kind of
Technology
you know another another kind of thing
is uh some of the questions about sort
of
the the qualitative understanding of how
the world works
there's been a long period of time when
it's all Machinery it's all mechanical
it's all Clockwork it's all the clock is
assembled this way and so the the the
the hands are gonna you know move in
this particular way we can open up the
clock and we can see what's going on
inside that's been the tradition from
the 1600s to today it wasn't the
tradition before that people didn't
think you could open up the donkey and
see how it worked inside and expect to
make predictions about what the donkey
would do
it's uh that is a thing of modern times
that was very much Amplified by the
Industrial Revolution and the technology
that came from that that is a thing that
as we work more on computation and we
understand ideas like computational
irreducibility the notion that just
because you know the rules by which
something operates it doesn't tell you
you can kind of immediately say what's
going to happen you have to just follow
those rules and see what happens well
the fact that there is this phenomenon
of computational irreducibility and the
fact that it says there are computations
where you just have to follow the
computation and see what happens and
that's the value of doing the
computation you can't just jump ahead
and say I know what the answer is
there's this kind of trade-off which I
think will be an increasingly discussed
thing between computational
irreducibility and controllability that
is if you just have to wait and see what
happens you don't get to say and I know
what's going to happen it's going to
always do the right thing you have to
kind of let go a bit of that if you want
to have the advantages of of computation
so to speak and the advantages of the
automation that you get from that and I
think that's going to be a sort of a
major debate back in and forth you know
to what extent do we want to rein in the
computers and make them only do the
things that we can readily understand
and have a narrative about and to what
extent do we want them to do great
things perhaps sort of behind the scenes
that achieve these particular human
objectives even though there are some
things that will go on that we do not
understand and that's going to be I
think that will be a a big kind of a big
debate of to what extent do we do we
want to have less wonderful things
happen but more predictable things
happen versus letting more wonderful
things happen with the recognition that
there could be things that go wrong that
we don't expect
and I think what we're seeing
you know I think there will be well
other things that will happen I mean you
know some of the things that uh
uh this idea that was an industrial
revolution idea that you can kind of
production line education
that you can put everybody in the same
class and they learn the same thing just
like everybody's going down the
production line and doing doing the same
thing
well that will no longer be a thing that
you know we can certainly expect that
there will be kind of a much more
personalized version of education and a
much different set of things that we're
trying to teach in in education and I
think there'll be sort of a post AI post
AI Revolution version of that that is
paradigmatically different from the uh
you know hosted Industrial Revolution
pre-ai version of that
um so that that's another thing I would
expect I think that this whole question
of uh
um
well a lot of questions about
oh for example
um
question about sort of the government of
the world and and how that works and the
extent to which sort of what we can
change and the way that works as a
result of sort of AI
um another set of interesting questions
you know I'm trying to think what what's
an obvious unintended consequence of the
same kind that was the sort of
stratification of society and the exit
and the emergence of cities that happen
from the Industrial Revolution I mean I
suppose some kind of uh uh utopian uh
thought which may not happen this way is
that there will be something a reversal
of those kinds of things
um in uh as a result of of uh of kind of
the AI Revolution I'm not sure if that's
really how it will work out
um I mean there may be unintended things
this is the life of computational
irreducibility there may be unintended
things I'm certainly not seeing about
what um uh what will happen and I think
um uh the
yeah I mean yeah very interesting
question well I should probably
um uh
um
wrap up here I I see from g-flat do you
think it's fundamentally possible for
science as we know it to hit a wall and
slowly degenerate
every individual area of science with
every particular Paradigm gets mined out
and it needs a new thing and possibly a
new kind of science to make further
progress
that's been the lesson of the history of
science the history of ideas in general
I think that this issue of
will we ever reach the end well we've
discovered everything that can be
discovered invented everything that can
be invented the answer is no in fact
computational irreducibility guarantees
that in a computational universe so to
speak you'll never reach the end of what
can be discovered what can be invented
there's always more to discover there's
always more sort of places where you can
find that little piece of computational
reducibility that lets you do a thing
that you couldn't do before the one
question which I think is an important
question is do we eventually say that's
enough
we've just we've got to the point where
we have everything we need we're living
happily ever after we just don't need to
know anymore
and you know at different times in human
history some uh some traditions some
cultures have gotten to the point where
they say we're good now you know we've
got what we need we're in a stable State
we'll just let things keep running now
in fact computational irreducibility
means that will always eventually get
blown up something unexpected will
always eventually happen that will
always lead one to sort of be pushed in
a different direction but I think that
the um the way that uh
uh the the real issue is you know do we
decide that
we're good now we don't have to push
further forward that's
um and that could happen there could be
periods of time where it has happened in
human history where there are periods of
time where people sort of say we're good
now and that can last for in the past at
least hundreds of years
um whether that's still true I'm not
sure although you know human nature does
have a certain constancy to it and until
sort of there are major changes in human
nature which I think will be associated
with things like effective immortality
and things like this
um it's uh you know that's we're stuck
with human nature as it is
um and so there will be some things that
I don't think will will really change
their Rhythm and character
all right I better go back to my day job
but thank you all for for a lot of very
interesting questions and comments and
uh I look forward to doing this again in
uh um well next week and and after
thanks a lot and bye for now